so are you in touch with adam you know
adam carolla you're your partner
speaking of speaking of bad medical
advice yeah
yeah he's he's he's making fun of people
for taking covet seriously i mean
wow what's going on with adam adam
doesn't believe in shampoo or soap
okay and in fact announced i think it
was
30 something days into it he was
announcing how long he'd gone without
using it
he got a horrible case of pink eye did
he really
[Laughter]
we're out in the backyard and um i
noticed adam urinating in their sandbox
and i go adam what are you what are you
doing he's like i'm peeing
i was like you're peeing in the kids
this is where the children play
why are you peeing in there you huge
backyard by the way
ah it's no big deal so this is the kind
of mentality we're dealing with when it
comes to health what is going on inside
his head
maybe he's burned because do you
remember a y2k
yes so i was laughing at everybody who
was panicking about y2k when it was
happening it's like i was like oh my god
not my computer we don't know what's
gonna
and it could turn and there's gonna be
uh looting and
and you know all sorts of mayhem and all
this craziness and
which just seemed preposterous you know
so uh we had a trip planned up to the
mountains to mammoth
and um adam and his friend donnie
decided to stay home
they skipped the trip because they
hadn't wanted to stay and protect their
homes from potential looting wow and
maybe he's maybe he learned from that
and he's like i'm never going to get
hoodwinked again i don't know what's
going on so he doesn't believe anything
he doesn't believe anything yes he is uh
you know the whole state is burning down
and uh
and he's run he's riding around without
a mess
and people are uh taking adam seriously
but he also doesn't
understand why we won't let him in the
house he he called my friend daniel he's
like
hey i'm outside daniel's like outside
what he's like outside the house and we
come in he's like no you can't come
come in but i mean he doesn't have a
grasp on reality does he i mean it must
it must disturb you
he doesn't believe in microbes yes it's
disturbing i hope he doesn't get it i
hope his kids don't get it
um i think you know what i think a lot
of people uh their motivation is their
parents and they want to make sure that
their
their parents don't get it adam doesn't
like his parents that much